hey guys I'm Ryan right hi I'm Veronica
so um there's a reaction get-together
happening and I did a video about the
reactive mania I did a little message or
a big beautiful black guy
Tyrone Magnus more like Tyrone magnet
cuz how can you resist him he's so
adorable with it huh that's my horrible
Tyrone Magnus impression anyway I have a
little message to him and he did a
reaction to the video I did which is an
honor that is awesome and we were
watching The Matrix Reloaded very
underrated film by the way I'm gonna do
like a little video about it we were
about to go to sleep til I saw that
Tyrone the man himself commented and
sent me this video I actually kind of
scared nervous yeah what if he's like
really mad at me so scared
well you're kind of keep making fun of
him I like the guy I know you like the
guy but like not everybody knows your
humor I know and I'm hoping he catches
him wasn't [ __ ] scary big buff black
guy a be seen his bicep he's in a
different where does he live I don't
know he's like six foot eight or so my
god damn giant
the old rejects I'll let you know I will
yes is so cool sometimes jokes funny
y'all got a message for me
he watches account yeah yeah let me just
click on my camera I'm on the phone this
Skype call with holy crap raucous all
right a kasam episode you have some
popular reactions out there I'm here
today because some nerve actually have
increasing the mean runner this putting
together reactor mania they wear a bunch
of hard-working reactors get together
and discuss stuff then we want to talk
about you don't appreciate a few other
people will be there there in the
description box so yeah
Gator Martin won't be there I met here
before he's a cool dude no disrespect to
Gator WTF very birthday of our asparagus
abuse than one of the big three protect
myself here at Derek Norman is really go
with whatever reason this doesn't look
entertained I'm kind of concerned
not about who you finery I'd run Sunday
she stays in the masturbates all day yes
you need their money I'm watching this
year I know that's the truth
John Max is going to be there you
mention your video Tyrone I am and we
tight between the two of us if you're
watching I can easily take your ass
that's why I would pay your body later
line to try would what my eyes you got
girl watching see money when you know I
got no girl right now
I don't want on something up via
I think what I'm talking about how a lot
of it so damn that of his Power Rangers
Power Rangers more medicine reactivate
the post the video decision intensity is
basically
ah he would know I don't so Tyrone ti4
time is really between ei sure this sort
of I think he's wanting to do that for
me Romania or maybe your watch doesn't
want to be a part of it out yes I need
Sherpa Soto wait your chest boobs
bouncing I've seen your pecs but here's
mine to Avakian wall San Jose California
time you do the cover with Pakistan
you'll be there you want to go be there
and I will be there and a bunch of
dummy laughs am I to come in this video
by cool video thanks umm no seriously
I've been actually working a lot lately
about my normal job soon the channel
will overtake financially but until it
does
I'm working a lot on my regular slave
plantation good meat job goddamnit
so got really in the present I guess I
work Sundays so you know is what it is
get touch with me for the next one for
the next reactor area man because then
you'll be able to get the master and the
three of you or the whole bunch other
think we're talking about brother what
you're gonna do with the real Regis ah
gah
son get a heart man hey yours truly I
already say the Mac sir
yeah runs one no and reactor India runs
wild haha if a like button with your
like my reaction it didn't like my
reaction hit the like button
alright here we go
my subscribers would have 100,000
subscribers black like it's like that
video No
subscribe but that's [ __ ] sweet
I always anticipated before that I never
seen that that's really cool I just
throw in an annotation and talk about it
he has like special effects and [ __ ]
he's got a [ __ ] subscribe button on
fire you're my number one but I want to
be Tyrone's number one youtuber he loves
you diagram I know we love ya he's like
my teddy bear
like my big like Papa Bear no that's
awesome
that was great that was great now this
is one of the best YouTube days of my
life
this really is happy to have you here
baby
tyrone one day youtube will most
definitely become your full-time income
that's going to be [ __ ] um i i bet
you have a lot more bills than what i
have but i'm fortunate and i wanted to
throw a thank you out there to
subscribers because this has actually
become this was able to replace my job
so i work from home and that's why i'm
eating a lot more videos up so thank you
guys so much and it's because a fun [ __ ]
like this it's to hard-working reactors
it's a hard job it's not as easy as it
looks you know hard it is to just be
yourself well your skype it's tyrone
it's a big [ __ ] I'm sure anyway yeah
well thank you guys for watching the
channel there's a subscribe button above
me and you could just hit the subscribe
button if you don't have it on your
computer
Veronica has a channel those covers and
vlogs and there's a subscribe button
there to need I need that exact same
subscribe thing but with like
Chippendales dancers around it mm-hmm
and like midgets yeah imagine
Tyrone's subscribe button Chippendale
dancers who are also midgets and I just
want to point out my chest muscles way
bigger than his way bigger wait wait way
bigger so much bacon ridiculous with you
was that he just made an ass out of
himself that's what he literally anyway
goodnight